phillies were held to a season low three
hits yesterday
and on the flip side the cardinals have
won four their last five games they've
allowed just 10 runs
we'll see if that continues tonight with
johann oviedo he came in a game april
11th in relief of daniel ponce de leon
it was terrific four and two-thirds
couple of hits walked two and struck out
four in 65 pitches
first strikeout of the night for johan
oviedo saw vince velasquez working out
at the bullpen and pitched effectively
that was in philly made a start against
the rockies on friday took a no decision
four innings five hits couple of runs 67
pitches
and a foul tip andrew knapp hangs on one
away
nine for 19 out of the number two spot
in the cardinal lineup and you can add
to that
goes down to get it two hops off the
wall carl's into second base standing up
with a one-out double
he looks so smooth right
yes he does
on time
line drive base hit it to right center
field and that's going to scoot all the
way to the fence
oh this could be three yeah they went
after it slowly but deeney's gonna stop
at second base
[Applause]
second double of the year for gregorius
can't let runners on base affect you
the 2-2
sway and a miss he struck him out his
second of the night
[Applause]
curveball shot the other way that's
going to drop in for a base hit
gregorius around third heading for home
he'll score it's an rbi single for
andrew knapp and the phillies are on the
board it's one nothing here in the top
of the second
first walk issued by velasquez
and it brings in tyler o'neill
lift it in the air out to deep left
goodbye
mccutcheon didn't even move he knew that
baby was launched
2-1 cardinals
andrew mccutchen didn't even move
gold schmidt
one ball count
weights as they play him straight up on
the
infield there's a fly ball in the center
field
herrera goes back it's at the track and
it is gone
paul goldsmith
with a home run to center field
much like o'neill's home run the center
fielder went back a couple steps to just
watch it sail into the seats over the
national car rental side
and left center field
and the cardinals extend their lead now
to 3-1
1-4 on the put out
back to the top of the order for brad
miller
2-0 to miller with a runner at second
base philly's down two
and a high fly ball out to right field
williams going back it is gone
and we're tied up at three
brad miller his second home run of the
season
it's a 3-3 game
a big one there by brad miller lined up
the one strike pitch
tommy sends that one into left center a
base hit
playing off the line mccutcheon the left
fielder gets to it
and holds tommy to a leadoff single in
the fifth inning
the 01.
high fly ball hit down the left field
line will it get foul
yes it will
and the catch made by the fan and he is
fired up high five high five
fist bump
don't fall over
[Applause]
swinging a miss that pitch was wicked
and he gets aronado
for the second out here in the fifth
14. finished that rookie year at a 270
oh man oh man hit him right in the face
it deflected into his face
[Applause]
hopefully when it hit his wrist
and then his arm and went up it slowed
things down a little bit
yeah that's
oh
i don't know if it hit anything fight
that it right in the face directly
wow
there's some jaune going from the uh
phillies dugout and now some guys
stepping up trying to get if there's
nothing gets even if there is get some
ice on and try to get that
he hits d.d glorious now and dede goes
down
97 to bryce harper oh this is what's
going to suck they're going to they're
going to warn both teams now probably
oh it's the big leagues if you if your
command's that dang bad
get out
go somewhere else they see andrew saying
something to him i don't blame him
that was 95
pitches one in the face one in the back
and now warned both teams so we can't
hit anyone
there's the warriors yes of course
and joe is not happy about that
he's out of the game of course that
would happen he's right too
joe threw him out first
and then james hoy
[Music]
let him voice his opinion he has every
right to don't walk him back to the
dugout
and then joe yelling it genesis cabrera
mike schilt yelling too
[Applause]
john you're aware of this more than
anybody else i mean that's two
95-97 miles an hour
two pitches two pitches
[Applause]
there's a line drive out to left center
field there's a base hit for mccutchen
rounding third heading for home is joyce
he'll score the phillies take a 4-3 lead
gregorius goes to third
an rbi single for mccutchen
we took a lead keep him there ella lines
one to left field that'll be in for a
base it a one hop off the wall
that's a little dividend after what he's
gone through the last couple days mom
and dad excited about that finally a
huge smile
popped up
out to center field
tagging at third is balm he's coming
home here's the throw to the plate it's
up the third base line he's safe at the
plate it's a sacrifice fly it's a 5-3
ball game
bottom of the ninth inning hector and
eris trying to close the door on this
victory for the phillies they lead it by
two ground ball out towards second dean
slipped maton has time throws to first
in time and the ball game is over a
scary night with bryce harper getting
hit in the face with a pitch and d.d
gregory as the next pitch getting hit in
the back but the phillies are able to
come from behind and win this one 5-3